well have you heard the saying good
things happen to good people tonight the
northwest community rallying behind a
teenager to help him replace a bicycle
that was stolen while he was working at
a local pizza shop
the response was so big they raised
close to one thousand dollars
here are the images of the alleged theft
they've been shared about eleven hundred
times on facebook
above the crust pizzeria right near ann
road in 95
says cameras captured a woman cutting
the lock and stealing
that kid's bike while he's at work
frustrating isn't it
it all happened sunday while jt a 16
year old in foster care was inside
to replace the bike they set up a
donation jar created a venmo account
jt's foster dad says the community
donated before they even knew
that he was in foster care i wish the
community would know
jt this is a 16 year old who's been in
and out of foster care his entire life
you know he's a straight a student at
centennial high school
it's become one of the biggest positives
in his life about paying it forward
about giving it back about doing nice
things for people you don't even know
well said to pay it forward to other
kids jt and the pizzeria
going to hold a bicycle drive on
saturday it's happening from 1 to 4 in
the afternoon right by the ann road 95
location everything raised will go to
eagle quest nevada that's an
organization that helps foster
and underprivileged children in our
community good job jt you keep working
keep getting straight a's and a bright
future for you forget that